round six of the 2016 sinkfield Cup  after a full day of rest of the best  players in the world came back looking  to make a move up the leaderboard  Grandmaster Peter Svidler desperately  needed a win against England but an  over-ambitious plan by the seven-time  Russian champion forced him to give up  his queen allowing China's number one  player to bounce back in the competition  defending champion levon aronian played  an enterprising pawn sacrifice against  Maxim vashi lagrave but his idea  backfired is the Frenchman pocketed the  point scoring his first win in the event  Castilian topalov looked to extend his  lead against one of his main rivals  Western so but a blunder by the  tournament leader gave the American the  win and the sole lead in the tournament  they are rounding the bend with the  finish line beginning to come into sight  the gladians of chess cross swords once  again round seven starts right now